[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes yes yes happy Tuesday everybody
yeah all right let's do it the Secret
Service is stumped by this baggie of
bump there you go remember when somebody
left a bag of cocaine in the White House
house and remember how the Secret
Service evacuated The West Wing and
closed off the streets surrounding the
White House initially everybody thought
Joe had once again left a floater in the
men's room then remember how one of
President Biden's precious children was
staying in that taxpayer funded facility
at the time because Joe wanted to keep
the impressionable youngster away from
bad influences or at the very least hide
him from process servers and remember
how Karine jeanpierre got really really
angry that the Press kept even asking
about it even though she didn't want to
talk about it can you just say once and
for all whether or not the cocaine
belonged to the Biden family you know
there has been some irresponsible
reporting uh about the family and uh and
so I got to call that out here I was
clear uh 2 days ago when talking about
this over and over the B family was not
here so to ask that question is actually
incredibly
irresponsible and and um
I'll just leave it there wow the way
she's reacting I'm starting to believe
maybe she sold it to
Hunter you know press secretaries don't
get paid that much it's true during the
Bush Administration Dana Pino was
selling injectable butt implants on the
turnpike her street name was
derera you also remember how the Secret
Service claimed they had no idea who
left the blow inside the most secure
building in the world that's harder to
swallow than Jeffrey dmer hot luck
meatloaf come on
people oh man that's tasteless but it's
like asking who is the hottest late
night talk show host the answer is right
in front of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you well that big cocaine headache has
returned the White House released new
pics of that pesky pouch of powder and
as you can see the culprit didn't just
drop the bag of happy dust all
willy-nilly it was stored in a locker
for cell phones it was locked number 50
to be precise which is most likely
unlocked with some sort of key that's
what the little Keyhole is for I learned
that by watching Law and Order and also
when I hide in the Planet Fitness locker
room so I got an idea why not find out
who has the key to Locker number 50
right I'm no Nancy Drew although I can
rock a plaid skirt but if you find the
person with the key to that Locker
you're one step closer to finding the
owner of that nose candy but who in the
world could be that forgetful to leave a
bag of coke behind you know Cavuto made
the same point today you always remember
our cocaine and forget our cell phone
not the
reverse I'm joking it wasn't Cavuto but
what will this unknown culprit misplace
next a
laptop according to the Secret Service
they could only narrow down the suspects
to 500 people despite all their
surveillance cameras and other
state-of-the-art security they just
couldn't figure out who it was so they
closed the case in just 11 days the same
amount of time it takes Joe to find his
way off
stage so here are the suspects so far
based on the symptoms we know about
cocaine abuse or use well it leads to
aggressive behavior like a certain bitey
dog named
Commander I know it could also lead to
Extreme Weight
Loss or perhaps deterioration in hygiene
habits and you can't count out those who
are constantly laughing and
dancing and you know some might say
she's a doctor which is a perfect cover
for running a drug
ring how about dilated pupils in
Non-Stop
gibberish and don't forget excessive
lying and of course there's all the
sniffling and
sniffing but there's someone we know it
can't be absolutely it's not him no way
don't even think about it no seriously
knock it
off anyway here's one reason why it
might not have been Hunter's Coke
according to a secret service report
obtained by The Daily Mail testing
showed that the cocaine was cut with
baking soda you know you got a thing 100
bucks up for the pure stuff am I right
we know we can afford it true this coke
was more stepped on than an American
flag at a college protest so other than
these new pictures why are we revisiting
this story well by way of comparison the
feds are still tracking down people who
entered the Capitol building on January
6 201 21 that was almost 3 years ago but
the feds are still on the case which
means they're probably innocent think
about it it's why they don't chase Rich
democrats for their crimes because what
do you do when you find out that they're
guilty you do nothing you can't your
hands are tied it's just better to chase
Trump supporters instead and then lock
them up so they nailed the guy who put
up his feet on Pelosi's desk but not the
criminal mastermind who left a bag of
Coke in the white house it's amazing
what the government can accomplish with
the proper motivation and what they can
specifically avoid doing especially when
they're given the order to stand down
the Secret Service used to be the one
Federal agency everybody could trust
they have the toughest job in the world
putting their lives on the line to
protect the president they have to swear
to take a bullet for someone which is
what I expect from kilme when we're out
in public
together but now they seem like they're
bumbling around trying to solve this the
simplest crimes either those agents
really are incompetent or they're just
pretending to suck at their job in order
to protect the Biden family which
likelihood is worse one thing is for
sure Hunter isn't losing any sleep over
this I wonder
why
period let's welcome tonight's guest
we're demanding a cease fire against his
Taylor host of fox Across America Jimmy
faala
she's funny talented and good-looking
wait that's me actress and comedian
Chandler
Juliet she's too small to tackle and
impossible to Shackle New York Times
bestselling author and Fox new
contributor
catb and he trims his beard with an
outboard motor New York Times best
selling author comedian and former NWA
world champion
pyrus
you know Jimmy since this is a story
basically you know about smuggling
cocaine into the White House we figured
you'd be the expert on at least
smuggling cocaine you'll never get you
in the White House what do you think is
going on here well I mean the truth is
it's Hunters okay we know that it's
Hunters because in order for the coke to
get into the White House it needs to
bypass security and only the family is
bypassing security you dig and if you've
learned anything from the laptop let's
be honest this guy has a lot of
suspicious packages you know what I mean
good night everybody that was done but
it's terrible I mean and the only thing
I would tell you as a takeaway because
I'm not a I'm not a drug dealer okay but
I'm going through this you just dress
like someone who's playing an undercover
drug dealer on 21 Jump streak I have the
I have the absolute opposite experience
this week you know like you can tell
what you look like based on how you walk
through Time Square on the drug dealers
approach you so like when I first
started at Fox I would walk through 42nd
street and the guy would be like yo
brother we got Coke we got smoke we got
weed I walk through this morning he's
like yo we got lipor we got OIC brother
you know what I mean you and your girl
going to sleep good tonight with these
Breathe Right Strips daddy you know so I
feel for the drug dealers but I feel
like at the same time like the lack of
interest in this story yeah is why
people hate the media for being
hypocritical okay they freaked out when
Trump brought Diet Coke into the White
House right okay this guy's showing up
with original recipe we don't get a gosh
dang word Chandler that's a really good
point and I'm surprised it came from
Jimmy after that terrible Breathe Right
joke but anyway no it's true it's like
remember when Trump was President they
were running articles constantly about
what drug he was on remember he's always
tweeting at night he must be on Aderall
or maybe he's taking some kind of speed
but here they don't seem to mind and
neither is the the FBI what do you think
of that you're right they said that he
uh his sniffle was that because he used
to do cocaine you're absolutely right
about that you know I think that they
couldn't come up with any suspects
because everyone in the White House does
blow now the only way they can get
through the day really um and it's
definitely not Hunters because it was
cut with baking soda yeah he would know
maybe they sent it to him and he tested
it out he goes no that's not the real
stuff that's mine I'll just throw that
in the locker yeah it's like baking soda
cat I mean not that I would know but
that seems like an odd thing to cut
cocaine with usually it's baby laxative
again not that I would know yeah I get
why it's so hard to find the person who
did this though cuz people who do a lot
of cocaine they never
talk
uh look I don't think it's Hunters
though because he smokes crack rocks
right yeah that was his whole thing not
he like to smoke the crack rocks and not
snort it right yeah that's true you're
absolutely right see I also think that
the investigation wouldn't be that hard
they said they've narrowed it down to
500 people they could narrow it down
further with one question which is want
a
bump I should be a detective you really
should I would watch watch the hell out
of a Law and Order SVU
T me too there you go I'm in so Tyrus uh
the story reminds me of a lot of stories
in the media where they don't bother
following up like we talked about like
how the homeless were just swept off the
streets in San Francisco and nobody and
where did they go nobody knows you find
Coke who does it belong to nobody knows
I guess we'll never find out no every
Everybody Knows and you know what I'm
proud of everyone in this panel you have
never sold drugs because you don't know
that baking soda is how you make crack
oh really so oh my word yes listen
people I'm going to educate you listen I
don't condone making crack okay but if
you must baking soda is important okay
so they boil it down you got to boil it
down and they use baking soda to rock it
up so he literally it was not his
cocaine he said I didn't have cocaine I
had precrack in a locker room but I
didn't have cocaine in the locker room
he would be the guy who would buy that
because he likes crack he smokes crack
so he if he does cocaine he would do the
same with the baking powder cut because
that's what he likes and it's cheaper
and those of us who seen the way he pays
child support he likes to save his money
yes so it's 1,00% his yeah everyone knew
it was his stuff plus I watch a lot of
Forensic Files before I go to sleep at
night and one of the things besides
seamen that gets men in trouble all the
time is these little things called
fingerprints right and plastic baggies
are pretty good at catching fingerprints
so it shouldn't have take very hard to
go one dust and be like oh we got a
print and it was a locker again surface
very good at catching the print so they
already knew they don't want they want
it to go away and they try to confuse
Americans saying we've got 500 suspects
toward my thing like great bring them in
I'd love to see the lineup yeah so we
know who it is it's his and it won't
come out till he's up out of there
because if it does get found out that
it's his he goes to jail yeah so that's
why the secret they're not they're
they're not taking a real bullet they're
taking a bullet for the president to
protect his son it's infuriating when
you I I think the contrast between this
and January 6 is really important
because there are people there there
there's no shortage of of Agents
investigating these people some people
that weren't even there you know and and
instead this guy it's just it's just unb
we could have wrapped this investigation
up I would have teamed up with Tyrus and
temp detectives walked in the room I'd
have put the light on them I'm going to
get a cup of coffee cat would have sat
down and be like want a bump yeah yeah
and then I would have come in care for
some baking soda and we would have had
it t would you have a catchphrase like
you know like like the guy yeah it would
be w a bump no I'm
kidding I would not have a catchphrase I
just love that Tyrus that you know the
crack recipe like I have a different
yeah I sold drugs when I was younger
I have a different Steve Ducey cookbook
I got to buy that one all right we must
move on up next data shows Trump's
cruising while Joe
[Music]
snoozing if you'll be in the New York
area and would like tickets to see
Gutfeld go to foxnews.com Gutfeld and
click on the link to join our studio
audience hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else